I actually didn't believe it was going
to happen because you know she was in
the script from from day one but I was
like I know what happened on the first
movie where we couldn't have Superman
this is gonna be this exact same thing
as in the first realm where you never
see the head people would have been so
mad oh another headless cameo
[Music]
[Applause]
we're finally here Shazam Fury of the
Gods it's been a few years how did the
story that you were going to do for the
sequel did it evolve over time yes
um we did first look at sort of what the
comic book has been doing recently the
Shazam comic book but it felt like that
was a little bit too fantasy and out
there because they're going into all
these different worlds so the room of
doors and things and we wanted to do
something that takes place in our world
something more grounded and bring all
the monsters and things here instead
um and that that's what it turned into
like hey you know his powers come from
gods and mythological figures what if
the powers were stolen and they want
them back you know because that would
give a cool motivation for the bad guys
that you can kind of understand yeah
because in the first Shazam the the
post-credit scene has Mr mind yeah and
so my my brain would assume that we were
going there for the sequel was that
originally what you were going to do or
yeah they were sort of this was part of
Mr mine's plan like he was the one
getting the goddesses to to our world
um that that was the original idea but
it turned into it was just too much
Story I mean the movie is already over
two hours without it you know so it
would have been a very long movie yeah
uh so we'll we'll see what Mr mind is up
to some other time I guess big question
I'm sure you're getting it a lot but
there's new leadership at DC Studios
with James Gunn and Peter saffron who
produced this movie what types of
conversations have you had have you had
any talks about the future of Shazam
well what they've said is that uh what
we're done in these two Shazam movies
doesn't contradict anything they're
doing with their new plans uh which is
great because it means that you know you
could do more Shazam movies if you
wanted to so we'll we'll see how that
all works out I don't know the full
plans I just know that there's nothing
in in these movies that would interfere
and there's
been post credits scenes that do like
speak to the Future
they obviously didn't get removed so I
feel like that's that's a good sign
right I think so yeah I mean there's
certainly a lot more you can a lot more
stories you can tell with these
characters than in this world would you
ever be interested in spinning off one
of those characters in like a series or
something like that absolutely I mean
and they are all quite different
characters I mean you could do something
with Mary for instance or Darla would be
fun you know I mean she's sort of the
most naive of them all and Freddie you
know they're all pretty cool characters
so you can do more with let's talk about
someone that shows up in this movie so
there's kind of like this gag and Shazam
I feel like it's a gag like where you're
like oh we're talking about these Heroes
but we don't know who they are we don't
really see them you kind of see like
Superman from the neck down and it was
kind of going on with Wonder Woman in
this movie until you're like wait how
did this come together well the we've
wanted to to poke fun at the first movie
where we you know we had to obscure
Superman's face and on this one I
actually didn't believe it was going to
happen because you know she was in the
script from from day one but I was like
I know what happened on the first movie
where we couldn't have Superman even
when we were shooting a lot of the scene
we had to gal couldn't be there when we
did that so we had to do it with a
stand-in and I was like this is gonna be
this exact same thing as in the first
realm where you never see the head but
then we actually were able to shoot with
gal
um and I mean that enables us to have
fun with it because if she hadn't and we
had you know teased all these things
people would have been so mad like oh
another headless Cameo and they would
just
I was
Soul originally like like close to he
was yeah and and that's the same thing
happened there where we had to shoot the
scene with a stand-in with the idea of
then going back and picking up his
pieces but then that never happens we
had to make do with the little pieces we
had which was kind of it's a funny
ending the way it cuts but uh we
wouldn't have gotten away with that in a
second now I wonder what this means for
the future of Wonder Woman yeah I mean I
think
I mean I don't know but I think she'll
be around yeah so there's this moment
where there is this man running and he
gets eaten by a
I can't remember what it is but he
looked he looked suspiciously like you
he's very handsome he was so handsome
who is that yeah you must know no it's
my first time doing like a an on-screen
Cameo where you've actually seen my face
but previously I've been like voices and
like creature performer and things like
that you're Mr mine aren't you I yeah I
am that's why I want to see more with Mr
mine because like I want that paycheck
I was like is Mr and like a like this
like gonna be this like ongoing gag
where it's like yeah I'll be back I'm
coming work I'm coming or is do you have
plans for Mr mine I mean it would be
cool just to see more because he's such
a weird and fun character like he said
little worm which is goofy as hell but
at the same time he is super dangerous
because he is really smart and he has
these powers and things
um so it would be fun to see you know a
superhero fight a worm uh let's cut on
that
foreign